il est 19 heures comme tous les lundis
après sa journée de travail
dylan s'installe dans le salon de son
mentor philippe hubert ce jeune apprenti
coiffeur ne s'arrête jamais au programme
de ce soir mise en plis et coiffure car
dans moins de 15 jours
il s'apprête à passer le concours du
meilleur apprenti au niveau régional par
contre après j'avais pensé plutôt que
les jours ici faire des boucles normal
parce que ça faisait un peu influent
dylan n'est pas encore sûr de la mise en
plis qu'il va proposer car le jury
évaluera la technique mais aussi
l'esthétique
alors évidemment on écoute les conseils
du coach je vais reprendre
philippe apporte son aide au concours du
meilleur apprenti de france depuis une
dizaine d'années en tant que jury ou
comme cette année en tant que coach
les professeurs du centre de formation
de versailles le conseil à leurs élèves
et pour lui il est tout naturel de leur
donner un coup de main c'est notre
avenir c'est l'avenir du métier
donc si comme on trouve des jeunes quand
on rencontre des jeunes comme ça qu'ils
ont la volonté d'aller plus loin que les
autres et de se donner à fond c'est
c'est un plaisir de voir ça aurait en
effet de les aider comme pour nous aller
avant philippe conseil dylan depuis
maintenant quatre mois et il n'est pas
son unique coach le dimanche direction
paris dans le salon délit eliakim fin de
la mise en plis et voilà que tombe le
verdict du mentor il ya des petites
choses toutes simples améliorer on peut
faire un dégradé tapant des boucles un
peu plus épaisse une
yens et même film et on finit par y ça
vous le faites au départ ça ce n'est pas
encore parfait mais heureusement il lui
reste encore quelques entraînements pour
fignoler
il est temps de ranger la tête à coiffer
car ces exercices ne sont pas terminées
place maintenant à la coiffure de soirée
et dylan a mis à contribution sa famille
ni dans le rôle du modèle sa belle soeur
sa cousine participera de son côté à la
troisième épreuve la coupe et la couleur
des personnes que je sais qu'ils vont
pas me lâcher au dernier moment
c'est parti pour le crêpage niveau
volume ça promet heureusement dylan
encore quelques soirées pour souffler on
le retrouve quelques jours plus tard en
famille chez lui à magny les hameaux
le jeune coiffeur a découvert sa passion
dès la maternelle
tout petit déjà il aimé rester dans le
salon de coiffure de sa tante ses
premiers cobayes sa petite soeur et sa
mère
de plus qu'il est vraiment dans la
coiffure alors la cbc les conseils il
faut voilà tu fais comme si tu devrais
pas faire comme ça on fait des mèches
ses parents n'ont aucun doute sur sa
motivation pour le concours et même au
delà
comment ils en parlent et à l'huile et
déterminés à aller au plus haut de deux
skips quoi
au niveau de la coiffure et puis surtout
comment les critiques les coiffures à la
télévision et si dylan est si critique
qu'il s'entraîne si dur c'est parce
qu'intégrer un plateau de télévision et
coiffer la star serait son rêve pour
l'instant dans sa chambre il se limite
aux têtes à coiffer mais le jeune homme
ne perd pas de vue son objectif c'est
carrément de choses qu'on fait sur des
plateaux que sur sur des gens de tous
les jours quoi enfin après c'est des
gens ils viennent une fois ils viennent
enfin ils viennent ils font leur couple
et puis voilà que sur le plateau enfin
déjà c'est pas la même chose ce n'est
pas la même qualité de travail c'est
fallait les mêmes conditions aussi et
puis enfin voilà quoi après ça passe à
la télé la commune qui donne au travail
fait cool on laisse dylan la tête dans
les étoiles
il est temps de le laisser se
décontracter avant l'épreuve de ce week
end